check one two this is the dumbest intro
that we're ever gonna do and I really
hope we cut it but I feel like I just
set myself up for somebody bad like
post-credit like both
[Music]
[Music]
kofi system lang secure it alpha
somewhat can YouTube yeah
after playing Call of Duty this weekend
I like call duty black ops for a lot and
YouTube seems to think it's real bad
like the worst Call of Duty that they've
ever seen some go through this video
point by point and they're like long
time to kill well I love it
like operator focus with these like
barbed wire they can't get through
because the defensive operators I love
it like body armor alright I'll give
them that
spawn flippin given that but like almost
everything else about this game like
objective based modes having to think
well wait for backup before you run into
a room like not being able to mow
through five guys because of all the
health I like it I like it and I like it
like these are all the things that are a
small step away from Call of Duty that I
think people who haven't play Call of
Duty for a long time like want to see in
this game so I don't know like who's
this game for because like traditional
cod guys don't seem to like that I don't
know I mean like I so I told you I think
like when we were first playing I was
like really upset I was like man this is
this is pissing me off because of like
the spawns are bad they're still kind of
bad especially if you play to the other
yeah I think once I gravitated away from
TDM and started playing the actual modes
the barbwire of torque and the torque
shield stuff I started to use that
instead of actually being upset about it
and that's when the specialist really
started to resonate and I was like cool
like this makes sense like all of these
different specialists abilities they
make sense because you know if you're in
a hard point you know the barbed wire is
good the shield's good you know cluster
grenade becomes like really good I mean
closer grenades good already because you
don't get a frag grenade to like look at
28 but especially given in those
settings like they all just start to
shine and the time to kill is actually
cool to me like I think it's better it's
not like you lived that much longer it's
like it feels like a couple more seconds
but that's a lot in cod time right so
people will get used to it I still saw
saw people shredding people if you're
getting headshots you're still dying
fast so I don't know I like it a lot
be advised start active boy beacon act a
it's interesting because I think you
said you played a bunch of team
deathmatch and that's when it didn't
make sense for you but once you started
playing objective modes that's when it
made sense and I think a lot of Call of
Duty players I don't know like I think
they're so comfortable with the idea of
just not having to think at that level
and just being able to run in and being
good with their weapon control and just
drop into user like flank II really
quickly that's what makes them happy in
this game is throwing a wider net which
like I get I understand why sometimes
that upsets people I think like a lot of
games when they throw a wider net I turn
off the core audience it's competing at
a time of hero shooters which is
interesting because hero shooters might
be on the way out because a battle rail
but this game is also gonna try and do
battle royale next month it's like we're
in this what does this game sit in your
mind like what is this game alright I
mean it'll be interesting to see where
it ends up I mean we were we've only
been able to play your traditional kind
of multiplayer called duty right but as
you mentioned blackout will be in beta
next month we'll get to see what that
looks like I honestly think that Call of
Duty maybe even battlefield that have
their the best shot have potentially
between the next big battle royale
outside of like pub G and fortnight just
because no Call of Duty has such a big
player base that then you know if they
even gravitate towards the bat blackout
battle royale mode that's already like a
success right granted maybe that's at
the cost of campaign which I don't know
I've never really cared about campaign
but you know some people are upset about
that we'll have to see if it brings new
cod players in I mean cod is such a huge
giant everyone like wants to you know
downplay it and say like oh it's just
another cod game like screw cod blah
blah blah what it sells right and that
just means that there are a lot of
players out there and that's why I think
blackouts gonna potentially be
successful just because that player base
is there it's interesting being a
franchise game I don't like I'm almost
like on a madden level where people just
come in to buy it every year again
they're there risking their base by
making changes I mean given like any
time any game exchanges people get upset
because they like what's comfort
I'm really curious with what's gonna be
the big shooter this year outside of for
tonight it feels like battlefield has
not really evolved much in years and it
feels like black ops is trying to take
like small baby steps away from the the
blackops formula and it also just has
this complete package again you know
like Battle Royale objective-based
slower combat and I like in my words not
yours but like I think raids I think
that like zombies kind of is almost a
raid in of itself well it's definitely
there like answer'd of PvE right or
something where it's a cooperative
experience where players get to fight
against an AI or like some type of it's
another thing to help replace campaign
right so and there's a huge fan base for
their zombies and I think it's cool that
they're gonna have like what three
different types like we're off the bat
in a way so interested to see I've never
been a big zombies guys but I know that
there's there's definitely a demographic
for that that are gonna be hungry and
ready to play that I'm optimistic I'm
hoping to have something else to play
other than fortnight as a shooter as you
mentioned at least in that battle royale
setting cuz you know i like cod
multiplayer so like having another like
layer like a battle royale could be
interesting but it's really hard to say
because we've only seen like little
snippets of that battle royale through
that like one trailer and it's really
hard to tell what that looks like or how
that's and i think this game could get
players like me back in college ET as
that kind of comfort game it's you know
what you're getting every night you can
go in and you can knock out whatever you
want to knock out that night and the
hero focus is really fun now because
it's weird to say this but i can have a
mane I really like nomad
I was having a really good time with his
mesh mines and dog attack
and just messing with the other team's
head and also you know again like the
defensive operators like I love playing
defensively I picked up the light
machine gun and you know SMGs we're kind
of dominant this beta I couldn't quite
hang on the front line but I could play
as an old man and you know like you're
saying we're getting older and you can
kind of sit in the back with the right
gadgets and the right scorestreaks and
make a have a big impact on the game and
like let the young kids do their like
SMG jumpy slighty stuff front of the
objectives
here
[Music]
blackouts were kind of has me hooked in
a way that as a lapse ecology player I'm
very interested yeah I mean I'm kind of
a similar boat I mean Call of Duty has
always been a game that I gravitate to
if my friends play and I was playing the
beta with a few of my old Call of Duty
friends and you know we all kind of felt
the same way at first especially playing
like team deathmatch but then as we
played it some more and then as we
swapped over to playing like you know
control so that was fun and my friend
had fun and like for us it's like okay a
couple of us by whatever by all gonna
buy it
so curious to see what blackout looks
like once we play that to get a better
feel for that beta again this weekend
gonna check that out obviously because I
think hopefully progression sticks and
we can just continue to level try out
more operator mods on the guns which you
know I think you might have almost got
to one I got two like two so there and
there's more that we can get to so it's
cool to see that you can also forget
progress a gun to the highest level
because there's actually something
potentially worthwhile getting there if
Cod wasn't already such a dominant force
I would say it's making a good return in
my opinion but we'll see you know I'm
optimistic though very optimistic hey
Tay I'm watching YouTube let's talk
about Cod I really just I can't I can't
take them seriously just I can't take
those serious